this isn't that as hard as you would get
like even in an HSE question this is
about as hard as you could get so feel
the difficulty of this don't feel bad
like Oh what do I even do this this is
we're getting to the endpoint right
let's have a look at this I'm going to
go through my process again having
already differentiated that should be
how I tie these up can I get some thumbs
up on that yes yes okay it's up there
are your stationary points I've just
solved for the numerator being zero
plugged it faithfully back into my
original function to get some
y-coordinates so now I know where I
expect my two stationary points to be
now that I have all that thought process
out of the way I come back to this guy
okay
that's what's saying honestly in reality
I would absolutely usually go through
this process first and then do this
because do you remember as I've started
to get say regions and that kind of
thing
this actually informs what you expect
out of here right you start to get some
regions that's an easy part right you
don't need any calculus for that and
then when you get to stationary points
once your regions are already there you
say oh of course I have two stationary
points nothing else can it make sense
right so honestly doing this person
might actually be helpful and the reason
I did this I asked you to do this verse
is so that you could have it out of the
way and we can just think through the
visuals of it so symmetry don't worry
about it
factorization it's factored ice okay as
far as I need it to be as you as you'll
see in a second I actually can factorize
it in a different way kind of that will
be helpful to me but it's it's extra and
you don't really need to worry about it
let's have the thing about the
asymptotes now okay there's a vertical
asymptote where is it x equals one one
we're still awaited then there we go x
equals one so I'm just gonna draw that
it x equals one please please please
label your asymptotes there's a lot of
stuff flying on your diagram if you
haven't done already do it
I've got my two for vertical but when
you go to think about well what's it
doing at the extremities you quickly run
into a problem okay because you
and you say okay the greeting here is
bigger than this so that makes you think
oblique but then you're like what kind
of big acetone is it okay now I'm going
to show you the cretan don't hack that
will get this of the gas attack for you
when we give it to polynomials the topic
I will demonstrate for you again because
I actually have to show you earlier this
one but I'll demonstrate it get in the
way you looked rigorously do this okay
so here's the hank version I'm writing
the numerator like this oops okay now
why do I do it this way okay I know in
advance that that thing at the top I can
actually divide through by X minus 1 if
I pair out this first okay that's
difference of cubes I know how to do
difference of cubes difference of cubes
same opposite always positive
oh you can't with that that's my
difference of cubes factorization and
then I've got my plus 1 hanging out on
the end because that's what I added to
make it balanced right that's divided by
Xmas minus 1 okay and then my X minus
ones cancel right I get left with this
guy which is a bit awkward he's hanging
out the front cross this time he
vanishes off to 0 at my extremities that
was the whole point of doing that
process right now like I said how do you
get this guy with that quick and dirty
hat but we'll talk about that in
polynomials okay you kind of need well
polynomial division and that kind of
thing but anyhow I've got it for now now
what does this thing look like like this
this is the asymptotes that I'm perching
at the extremities okay you don't can I
emphasize it you don't need to know
exactly where this is you don't these
know exactly where it is okay you can't
work out where it is if you wanted to
like if I gave you this question just
graph this and tell me everything you
know about it you can find everything
you know about it for instance the
discriminant is b squared minus 4ac
which in this case is negative 3 so how
many rinses they have none okay the
leading coefficient is 1 which is
positive so that means it's positive
definite
and you can workout you can do the axis
of symmetry you can work out exactly
where that is not the emphasis of this
question okay for all intents and
purposes this will do this is roughly
what it's doing okay we will notice it
does not hit the axis because like I
said positive definite okay
but I'm not I'm not fussed about that
that's not gonna figure so the question
I've got the asymptotes out the way
what's my big step it deserts intercepts
okay I look at the numerator and I see
there is one and only wanted to set
namely the origin right say BAM a
postulant through them okay done by
intercepts all right regions regions
regions you think what can I do with
this thing okay now it's a bit funny
because x cubed x cubed as a as a graph
you know what execute looks like right
it looks like this but remember I'm
trying to make things easier for me no
harder why am i drawing these fact
aligns it's only to worry that sign like
where is it positive and where is it
negative now do you see that the sine of
X cubed negative u positive here is it
not exactly the same as the sine of y
equals x look they'd make it into the
same places they have positive in the
same places so reader guide to my factor
lines I'm just going to draw black was X
it will do the job of X cubed for me
that's fine okay so hey good days why it
was X and then I have one other factor X
minus one so it passes through here done
there are my two factor lines okay so
having done this I can do my regions
never write two negatives positive
positive negative it's just gonna
alternate isn't it you're used to this
yeah and I finish up here okay
there are my regions now that I've gone
through this whole process I come back
to the stationary points I found earlier
right so there's one at zero now I know
it's there I look carefully at the
regions don't go to the second
everybody don't do a table values tell
me what kind of stationary point that is
it must be a horizontal inflection look
it's got to decrease through here go
horizontal and then it's gonna keep
decreasing again horizontal point
inflection in fact what can do is this
there's my horizontal point inflection
okay it's a bit maybe over one side but
that's Mike that's what it's gonna do
it's gonna protect a center okay I have
another stationery where is it it's at
one and a half six and three-quarters
right so if this is one mark this okay
you will get caught on doing being
inconsistent with your own horizontal
scale so I said that's one so that means
that that would be two
so wonder half better be halfway between
those right now luckily for me I have no
other like really important vertical
scale so I can put the six and
three-quarters more or less wherever I
like but based on where this loops like
I don't put it somewhere like that so
that would be where my stationary point
is I don't need a second derivative tell
me the nature of this stationary point
it's got to be a minimum